I believe that right there is the
definition of entrepreneurship it's when
you love your game more than what the
game gives you you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
Gary Oh Donald Jersey what's up jet fans
dot Darnell and Leonard I love it you'll
warm already I love you back mom exactly
everyone thinks that they already know
you and think they can just talk to you
whatever they want they can I'm like I
love you back I think the I think you
know social came along the Internet of
evolution came along at a very good you
know life is so much about timing
you know I was born in the former Soviet
Union and if I was my grandfather I'd
probably be in a Soviet jail during this
time of my life and I'm not kidding
because both my grandfather's spent time
in a Soviet Jail I happen to have the
serendipity of timing where the internet
came along and created a framework that
allows people to interact at scale I
disproportionally enjoy human beings I
actually secretly dislike animals
because so many people like animals more
than other humans and it always breaks
my head so they can come up to me like I
like being accessible people you know I
like saying hello I love the idea of
like that one moment in time that I get
to meet somebody and so I'm super
interested in meeting all seven point
eight billion people and so yeah I feel
that way about them too
that's good I mean you can be you can
tell and we're going to talk a lot about
authenticity and being you know knowing
who you are you know you came four years
ago sort of blew into my class sat up
there no questions you know some people
just get out of the way because you just
know that they're gonna do it without
you and you gave a 45-minute talk it
felt like it was off the cuff it was it
was so powerful I mean that really was
like a great and he was here it was
really spectacular and then you years
later you gave us credit for like
helping blow up your Facebook platform
that really good talk yeah that that
talk you know I was telling some people
right before thank you for that invite
and and it was definitely off the cuff
I'm only comfortable and improv you know
I'm look I stay in my lane I talk about
what I know and I don't talk about what
I don't know and that makes everything
very easy and off-the-cuff it was an
interesting time because four years ago
you know again back to timing when I
walked into that classroom it was
clearly the time where something had
transpired to me which was a concern
that entrepreneurship was about to
become Rockstar status and if you listen
to that talk I'm coming aggressively but
it's out of love not disrespect I have
at that point and way more so today I
have a concern that we're living through
the greatest era of fake
entrepreneurship
I believe that self-awareness is
incredibly important and I do believe
that the coolness of entrepreneurship
has made people go towards that light
that might actually be way better being
a number three or number six or number
nine and so in that you know I mean the
opening line in the class was I don't
think entrepreneurship can be taught and
where I was going with that
so that's awkward he says and where I'm
going with that is actually I refined
that message because it was the first
time I've ever said it I think of
entrepreneurship so much more similarly
to sports I could be better at
basketball right
I could play every day I could you know
work on my left hand I could you know do
things that I would be substantially
better in a year and a half I just never
had a shot of going to the league and I
think that there's a big difference
between being an entrepreneur and being
a successful entrepreneur and that's a
conversation that I subtly found myself
bringing to the forefront four years ago
in your classroom and then what happened
was we got serious about Facebook on my
end and we chopped up that keynote into
a lot of different points and many of
the clips from that talk went on to get
disproportionate virality so you were
great the team around you was great the
campus was great the vibe was great it
was just all good stuff and you know I'm
really really happy to be here again
it's it's great to have you back it is
sort of by back by popular demand we we
have a series every Wednesday and so I
asked the students like midway through
the semester you know if you have
anybody who would it be and they started
naming some people and then all of a
sudden you felt this vibe just like we
want an influencer one social media
wants on most people and then someone
yelled Gary Vaynerchuk in the whole
class just starts going yes yes yes and
at the time sort of we started talking
about it so like it might happen maybe
it'll happen and then when it did they
really were pretty pumped so there are a
lot of students missing other classes
tonight to be here
that's decision of your career I'm very
confident about that yeah we're gonna
get we're gonna get into education in a
minute but first I the thing that struck
me with so much clarity and you know
sometimes you hear something is just the
way someone said a little differently
and it really was your message around
self-awareness and knowing your
strengths could you sort of not
everybody heard that can you tell us
what you mean by that
and why you said it's the most important
thing for an entrepreneur I think of it
in in practicality I I don't think you
get the same returns by overwhelmingly
working on your weaknesses as you do on
tripling down on your strengths I don't
know what else to say
like it's it's so clear to me I think so
much of what I talk about is predicated
on not only my successes but watching my
family members watching that whole
ecosystem of startup founders just
watching I watch a lot I read a lot of
like people's behavior more so than you
know books or things of that nature and
so yeah I mean I just I believe that the
entrepreneurs that have gone on to
quadruple down on their strengths and
then hire around their weaknesses have
had much better success than the ones
that dwell on their shortcomings because
somebody they look up to was good at it
and said it was important and they waste
her time on something they'll never be
yeah yeah I mean there's you could spend
decades of your life try and improve on
some of those weaker things when really
if you really just understood what makes
you unique and what makes you different
and better there's some things are yours
better at and if you can't practice them
you get even better and almost
everything is a commodity like most
things are commodities like Omo
nothing in the scheme of things there
very few things that matter and most of
the things that actually matter are
predicated on emotional intelligence not
on information you know and deploy so
you know I don't know I just you know
and then you get into other things like
when you talk about the current state of
startups and venture capital and the
whole thing we're living in the greatest
era of financial arbitrage machine's not
actual businesses everybody's life right
now is about CAC and LTV and hitting
metrics to get the next fundraising
round and has nothing to do with the end
consumer its b2b finance game on the
back end and that's why so many people
are gonna lose and yeah you still think
it's a great time to be an entrepreneur
in terms of the ability to raise money
and they're you know well to me it's not
the last part but yes I mean raising
capital is a piece of cake
today at a level that we've never seen
it's ludicrous
you know the youngsters in this audience
think it's normal to get somebody to
give you money based on your idea at a
four million dollar or six million
dollar valuation that makes me want to
punch you in the face
because for anybody in here who's over
40 that is a ludicrous concept but that
is what happens when there's an enormous
amount of money pumped into the system
on the back of us not paying the piper
properly in 2009 because we're soft as a
culture and so this is a very fake
entrepreneur environment like when I see
entrepreneurs that are failing in this
environment with how much capital with
how little it costs to be in the game
with the Internet at full scale like if
you're an entrepreneur that's failing
right now that's a year or two in you
suck
I mean it you suck it entrepreneurship
doesn't mean you suck I suck at piano
but let there be no mistake if you're 18
to 24 months operating a business in
this environment and you're not winning
with all those advantages you're not an
a and I think it's important because you
don't have the perspective of history
for people who are 20 years old you know
you're a lucky time where you can raise
a half a million dollars on a an okay
idea what happened what are kids their
age in 2008 when they graduated what did
they have to do not do that yeah go get
a job correct yeah so it's a unique time
to be an entrepreneur you referenced it
which is which you know gets into
entitlement and being soft and then
people think their ideas are good cuz
and it gets it gets really convoluted we
need a correction you're talking about
who's a person who's disproportionately
benefited by the cool factor of
entrepreneurship but I don't want that I
appreciate it like as you can imagine
like coming on stage and getting this
kind of love from the 20 year old set
it's like something I could have never
dreamed of it feels remarkable but but
I'm unbelievably passionate about over
communicating the shortcomings of an
environment where entrepreneurship is
cool it's it's the same way that being a
professional athlete and a rapper is
cool very few people can actually
achieve it and a heavy high-level
success so two things are passed are
important to me one I want to redefine
what a successful entrepreneurship path
looks like like if you make a hundred
thirty six thousand dollars a year on a
business that you run that you like
doing around something you like and you
can live that lifestyle that is a
remarkable feat but that is not the
picture we're painting of a successful
entrepreneur we're painting private jets
and islands and all sorts of [ __ ]
ludicrous [ __ ] you know and so hey I
think it's remarkable I mean we need a
level set the one-percent earners in our
country one of the research countries in
the world the bottom of the one-percent
make four hundred twenty thousand
dollars a year yet like everybody starts
the conversation of macro big success
out of million bucks
like we just--we're twisted and we also
have to talk way more about happiness we
also have to talk about what it looks
like to have a scarlet letter of an L
when your company fails in a world where
you've never had a public loss in your
life because you've played through a
school system there's a lot of things
that we have not addressed there are a
lot of people right now that are
flossing on Instagram as entrepreneurs
who are gonna go into deep depression or
even suicide when they take a massive L
on the next correction in our economy
and that's going to be tough it's sort
of pretty deep things to start with but
yeah if you if you are
but you know Kerry dives right in you
know if you know and in talking about
mindset and you're hitting we have one
of the leading researchers on purpose
based identity as opposed to achievement
based identity where people tie their
self-esteem and their their life to how
you know results and success you know
spoiler alert you're not gonna be happy
and so finding a purpose and aligning
with your identity that you're going to
lead a much better life you could be
productive over a longer term and you're
probably not going to hit those lower
flows that you talked about I want to
step back really quickly because you
mentioned it but I want to talk about a
gear that you feel you have and why and
so for those of you who don't know your
background can you talk about your
family where you grew up and how you
grew up I grew up really lucky in the
fact that I had disproportionate
adversity in the first decade of my life
you know I was born in Belarus we came
to the US when I was three I lived in a
studio apartment with eight family
members you know it was super immigrant
right we didn't speak English
like you know my dad I didn't even know
my dad until I was 14 years old and
started working in his liquor store
because he woke up to go to work before
I woke up and he got home after I fell
asleep I went on one family vacation in
my entire life you know were - excuse me
- in my entire high school life both the
Disney World in Orlando
you know stayed in a Holiday Inn like we
kept it humble we didn't buy dumb [ __ ]
you know like you know I basically wore
liquor t-shirts my whole life through
high school cuz they were free from the
liquor store like the level of humility
and a lot of my ability to not worry
about others was predicated on
circumstance like you know and I really
think that I'm the beneficiary of very
good parenting and very lucky
circumstances and those lucky
circumstances in my mind was I was never
handed anything ever ever and I
genuinely when I hear stories and
culture of people thinking people that
are trust-fund babies are lucky I just
don't see the world that way I actually
think they're disproportionately unlucky
it would be my great devastation to end
up being my children or my grandchildren
I mean it that's just the way I'm wired
it doesn't mean they're wrong or I'm
right it just means that for me the way
I turned out the chemicals in my body
the thought of being handed something
were starting with that kind of thing
where my achievements would always be
undermined because everybody would say
that it was handed to me would be
devastating
that's the challenge of your next part
of your life is raising a boy kids and
keeping them on the ground oh it's gonna
be a piece of cake I'm not giving him
any [ __ ] money I I grew up in I grew
up judging Bill Gates and Warren Buffett
when I was younger of giving away their
money because I grew up in an immigrant
family were you like you help each other
and I judged them heavily and I was
super wrong cuz I had no context I was
like that's crazy to a charity like what
and now I understand I want my kids to
be happy and I do not believe that
disproportionally paying for their life
style puts them in a position to be
happy I really don't I do not believe
that on the flip side kids love to [ __ ]
on their parents for doing that but
don't stop taking it
you're gonna get lukewarm applause at
USC some of the kids scare like their
parents are there with the parent it was
a it's a it's a really important point
I've been talking a lot about look I
hate I hate when people [ __ ] on
Millennials because the people that are
[ __ ] on the Millennials are the one
who [ __ ] raised them here they're
[ __ ] on the byproduct of what
they've created on the flipside when I
say that the kids love that and they hit
me up on DM they're like yeah [ __ ] my
mom she gave me too much like [ __ ]
hate I hate it and I'm like and I reply
and I'm like cool dude so give up
unlimited uber [ __ ] get off the
[ __ ] payroll if you're so [ __ ]
unhappy but kids talk out of both sides
of their mouth because they're
hypocrites because they want to floss in
front of their friends but what they
don't realize is the quickest way to
happiness is to stop taking the money it
is it's awesome it's a lesson that
you've never done it's hard to learn as
you're younger in that age as you get
older it's super easy to learn you just
have to realize that it's true and you
have to start valuing the opinions of
your friends you have to start valuing
stop okay yeah that's what I've said
yeah I was like that goes against
everything that I think we're teaching
but can you and so why do you feel with
your upbringing and that that's an
advantage why did you sort of always
feel you actually told my class like I
just feel you can't beat me straight up
why do you feel you have hey that was
fun yeah what why do you feel you sort
of have a gear because is it because you
really enjoy the process in the words
don't think anybody look I do not think
anybody who goes to college and studies
entrepreneurship can beat me in
entrepreneurship that doesn't mean it's
right and it's just kind of how my brain
works like I feel like it's a crap like
I don't think like I think it has asked
we have not defied entrepreneur
entrepreneurship properly here
why again I absolutely believe people
that go to school for Entrepreneurship
can get better at entrepreneurship from
that process
I desperately believe that
entrepreneurship is a talent similar to
see singing and playing sports and I
think that I'm on that spectrum and that
gives me confidence in this one little
narrow thing about entrepreneurship
because while everybody else was
studying in school and like playing
sports and doing whatever they were
interested in I was constantly
entrepreneurial right and so I just have
so much natural ability and so many
years of practice that I feel like on
the extreme and that's why I'm confident
about it and so yeah I mean chip on
shoulder right no and that's the only
gear you've ever known if that's what
you've been hustling since you're a kid
you always look at what was the kid
doing when he or she's younger did she
have a paper route did she hustled you
know whatever it was and you can tell
when kids are on the right track and
entrepreneurship is scary and you have
to fight against the system and you have
to see things others don't and you have
to challenge norms and I quit school in
third grade you know like I did like
it's super weird but like I started
getting D's and F's in fourth grade I
consciously walked into fourth grade and
said I'm out I did I did and it was
mainly because for who knows why and I
really have no answer for this but I
just remember I mean fourth grade you
rich I mean you're a babe it's a it's a
it's I'm looking at like other for like
it's crazy to me that I actually had the
thought process of this isn't for me I
know who I am
I'm gonna be this and I don't care about
the periodic table you know I want to
look you you might not even know what
the [ __ ] periodic table is
is that the elementary molecular weight
of compounds yeah I'm out yeah but I
think you'll like this and that so a
place guys see and I you're backstage in
here like we have every resource
available for for entrepreneurial
students faculty staff so incubators
accelerators a fund but here's the thing
that I think you're gonna like so we've
been saying this the last few years so
we're the members of the football team
here and the coaching staff like you
know some of the best recruiters of
talents in the world here we recruit now
we recruit entrepreneurs at USC like we
recruit dancers and musicians and
absolutely right now people here I I'm
so pissed that would have been really
cool for me look I mean it I mean it
like that would have been like that's
super rad because we look you know it
students coming in with perfect AC tees
and perfect scores they may not be
entrepreneurs are ready for that they're
used to perfection and you just doing
really well they're not ready to launch
at 22 some of them some people are but
we say go find me a kid who really is in
it to win it and like bring us that
person even if she doesn't have perfect
scores he's a natural talent yeah it's
not even in it to win it the SAT perfect
kids are in it to win it it's talent
that matters like I'm in it to win it to
be a [ __ ] pro football quarterback
I'm [ __ ] in it to win it it's not
gonna happen
and and I we do not have the proper
context around entrepreneurship we until
we start understanding the level of
talent involved in it we will always
undermine how difficult it is because we
think it's a process and that doesn't
mean I again this is why underlining
that we have to contextualize how
awesome it is we have to start putting
on a pedestal starting a
direct-to-consumer you know Jam business
on Shopify where you make 183 thousand a
year because you love making Jam cuz you
and your grandma made it and like that
being a massive success cuz you're happy
as [ __ ] and you can live your lifestyle
and you live under the means of 183
thousand a year we have to put that on a
pedestal that is when entrepreneurship
can hit its golden era this notion now
of everybody building next Instagram is
ludicrous talk yeah I mean a good friend
of mine a good friend of yours actually
I had a good business 80 employees sold
it to a public company and I grew up I
grew up poor and I thought you know you
start a business to sell it you don't
you start a business you have a business
to have a good life it if it cash flows
and makes money I'd be very reluctant to
sell it unless you really think it can
be obsolete so like you don't start a
business to sell it you build it
everybody starts a business now to sell
it that is the culture they grew up in
yeah there's nothing like having a
business that's why everybody's building
financial arbitrage machines they're
just fundraising to the flip everybody
wants to be 26 at a trillionaire and
[ __ ] have a jet and a [ __ ] baby
giraffe and [ __ ] cold
it's [ __ ] so so you've talked about
a couple times how do you do you know
that the relationship between success
and failure well how do you define
success and how is it related to failure
I define success as waking up and being
happy and being able to do what you want
to do at all times yeah and as a parent
would you rather have your kids be
successful or happy
that's an easy one right it's super
simple and like and we we we are
absolutely at an inflection point where
there's people like me and different
things happening where we're starting to
have different conversations like
nothing freedom is what everybody's
chasing but they're confused about what
it actually looks like it's not how much
you make it's how much you spend there's
a lot of people could be way more free
if they didn't overextend themselves on
what they're buying what's keeping up
with the Joneses yeah it is the poison
of our society it is so that's your
definition of success what's what's the
role of failure and why again putting
micro failure in the process are you
asking me the the role of failure in
getting to success as part of it if it's
right you you can do is it related is it
a necessary part you know there I put
myself in a group of people who like you
know you don't want to fail when you're
younger it's gonna be embarrassing you
know you've had all these successes
you've done well in school you've done
wrong and to have a failure and now you
know I think that's the one thing at
this point my life like did I take
enough risk did I put myself out there
that we didn't so you definitely did not
yeah I here's how I know it
I again one man's point of view I'm not
sure anybody is taking enough risk from
20 to 30 it is the most interesting
thing that I've been thinking about
which is it is never more practical to
be disproportionately risky than from 22
to 30 yet everybody goes the other way
because now they're the real world and
it's time to prove something to their
parents to themselves to everybody else
and everybody goes conservative it is a
huge mistake we need to flip it upside
down everybody should go ham from 22 to
30 and do a ton of ridiculous [ __ ] and
figure themselves out but but on your
own dime not your parents there's the
parents clapping so so how I think about
it is you should go and be rogue and get
to know yourself and taste [ __ ] from 22
to 30 but you have to live by the
ramifications of doing that and the cost
of entry of that is living with four
people in a studio apartment eating dog
[ __ ] food and not having fancy [ __ ] when
you go and do that but you're being
subsidized by your parents then you're
living in a fake environment and you're
super [ __ ]
so so tell us about failure and why it's
important - I love it yeah because I
love it
I like micro failure I like micro
failure I hate macro failure like death
of your business is bad but but to me
you know it's funny I'll use a boxing
analogy my favorite boxing but I watch a
lot of boxing
I think boxing's are very interesting
and I know and I'm super into mixed
martial arts but I grew up on boxing I
understand it better and I like watching
it because there's so many things that
happen in boxing first of all what I
love about boxing is there's nowhere to
hide you know like it's super
interesting right there's nowhere to
hide number two there's something
there's a scenario boxing that I love
the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round and then go on to win the fight
easily it's an interesting psyche right
and I like that and this is what I'm
thinking about it which is like here's
what's bad in boxing and in business
going into a fight getting knocked the
[ __ ] out in the first round and losing
the match bad getting knocked down and
then having the adversity to readjust to
what you got caught on and navigating it
too easily when a fight is remarkable
that's how I think about
entrepreneurship people the reason so
many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is you have micro
failures almost daily and they're very
in-your-face you can't hide and I like
that I like failure I'll because I think
I deserve it I hate when people don't
respect the game when I fail it means I
[ __ ] up and I like that because I
think people get audacious my number one
thing that I hate about capitalism is
that people use it and they love it and
they're big capitalists and they love
open market and competition and all that
and then they become 73 and they try to
use all their money to protect their
money they're not willing to let a young
lion eat them the way they ate somebody
else I hate when they try to manipulate
it that's what I love about sports what
I love about sports is when you're 36
and you were once the best player in
but now you're getting a little bit
older and your body breaks down you are
forced to retire the one thing that
entrepreneurship and capitalism has to
adjust to is once you get old and you're
tired and you want to be on a yacht
instead of working your [ __ ] you should
lose some money because you're losing
and in that part you know we bring up so
many great entrepreneurs and you're one
of them too you hear all the successes
and I think it gets romanticized a lot
just how ridiculously difficult
stressful sleepless nights and I do
think you have to experience failure
because you learn just the way the human
being is wired you're gonna learn 10x
with with some failure than you are
actually getting excited here or let me
let me let me frame it up a little bit
different or you love it so much so much
that you never were able to do anything
else and just the process of playing the
game is the success itself or you love
it so much that you actually don't give
a [ __ ] about the trophies aka the money
that comes along with it it's that you
just wouldn't know how to breathe
otherwise if you weren't in the process
of entrepreneurship itself I will never
fail because there is no failure the
at-bat is the macro win if I lost all my
money because I did 37 ridiculously bad
decisions and over leveraged myself the
ability to go back to zero and try to
like buy [ __ ] at the dollar store and
flip it on eBay and build the back up
weirdly excites me more than where I am
right now I swear on my children's
health no kidding
the thought of going to zero having all
of you judge me as see he wasn't as good
as you thought and then rising back like
a phoenix and sticking it in your
[ __ ] face excites the [ __ ] out of me
I believe that right there is the
definition of entrepreneurship it's when
you love your game more than what the
game gives you that's why I like losing
the game told me I lost respect to the
game that's why I liked playing I did
this when my friends I was an
entrepreneur when there was no
conversation around this in the 80s and
90s school system and society that I
grew up in I was a failure for making
$2,000 a weekend selling baseball cards
like I did this when it wasn't cool I'll
do it now while it's cool and I'll do it
again in 15 years when it's not cool
again because the economy will collapse
and because we don't like to be
accountable we like blaming things and
so we're gonna blame entrepreneurship
not the fact that you weren't self-aware
and didn't realize that you weren't a
[ __ ] entrepreneur that's right
it's it's funny last year Kobe sat and
it's almost the exact same things he
said about practice like he loves
practice
he loves beating people up in practice
embarrassing people in practice so much
about the process not the result a
hundred percent a hundred percent like I
when people ask me what's your failures
I've got none I found my place I will do
it in perpetuity and the gratitude that
oozes out of my soul is why I put out so
much content the way I do
cuz I'm desperate to give back on
something that I realize I was gifted by
circumstance and I feel a level of
gratitude and almost a level of guilt
and a need to communicate in a framework
that so many people in this room did not
have the luxury of that Northstar or the
ability to stumble into their perfect
place you mentioned like you know coming
back and rising like a phoenix and
phoenix and and sort of telling people
it reminds me of a story you know a long
time when now this seems you know almost
accepted but when you were on as a
purist Morgan or something and Facebook
just bought Instagram for a billion
dollars you know that the companies how
many months old eighteen months old 13
employees and it sold for a billion
dollars and people were just astonished
like how could Facebook over pay that
much for Instagram and you said famously
on television what you say they stolen
they stole it and at the time you're big
on Twitter still are and I got [ __ ] on
to tell people what happened that night
what what happened that night when you
went home and fill the story out I get
out of studio felt good about my spot my
mom said I look cute you know
and I went on Twitter and everyone's
like this guy is completely lot like
just got completely destroyed like this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
like this will go down as a colossal
failure like just got killed you know
and it seems ludicrous now given that
Instagram is the entire universe but at
the time most of people that were
watching haven't even heard of it let
alone thought it was worth a billion
dollars so the part that you're bringing
up is what you do that night you know I
read them all and favorited them and
then and then three and a half years
later went on vacation and laid on a
beach but well first of all what wait
but then what happened though Facebook
bought whatsapp for eighteen billion and
you know and it kind of put the light on
Instagram being a great deal it's even
more obvious how great of a deal it is
now and I got a couple of pina coladas
sat down and replied to every single
person and said now what dick
yeah that's an entrepreneur it's it's
somebody who loves competition I love
this game
yo dude you're leaving respect so so to
me it's somebody who loves that's a
competitor that's a competitor I love
this game I love it so much I'm worried
about how its positioned because I think
it's just it's slightly mispositioned
I'm trying to be very I'm trying to take
the responsibility of a lot of eyes and
ears on me to bring this conversation
because I think if we tweak it a little
bit it could be remarkable because I do
think this is the greatest year of
entrepreneur the Internet is remarkable
it's so hard for a lot of you in here
cuz you don't know a world free internet
bless you but I know a lot of us I know
a lot of us in here as I look around
we're alike remember real life without
the internet existing and and the and
the depths of what it allows us is
remarkable and if we can just tweak it
around happiness instead of around
success for others it can get really
really really good because it's never
been more practical to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year selling
something on the internet that you like
whether that Star Trek memorabilia or
flipping sneakers it's super real but
everybody's going for a trillion when
they don't have the talent for that
which is making them miss the 400,000
and happy and they're gonna go for the
trillion and miserable and I'm trying to
tweak that you uh do you have a personal
philosophy that yes share I want to give
more than I took because I want the
selfish selfish leverage of that
explain what do you mean I want to give
more than I took because I don't want to
owe anybody anything and I want to pay
back the gifts that I was naturally
given because my parents had sex at the
right moment so I've watched you I mean
I don't know like it might have been a
big snowstorm in Russia that day and
they like anything could have happened I
mean this you know this is one of my
most viral pieces of content I love that
everybody's so into math and big data
and quant and have not deployed the
level of gratitude around the math of
four hundred trillion to one which is
the odds of being a [ __ ] human being
there's nothing you'll ever accomplish
that's more remarkable than that you
have a chance to accomplish something
if we can lean into gratitude a lot of
good can happen I don't know I'm just
super grateful and it is an enormous
there is no Red Bull there is no [ __ ]
soda or coffee that comes anywhere close
to gratitude people think I'm [ __ ]
drugged the [ __ ] up
I haven't even smoked a cigarette in my
life because my mom got [ __ ] Nancy
Reagan you know and so so I just came to
realize oh [ __ ] this insanity is
predicated on gratitude when you're so
grateful for the at-bat you're happy but
people dwell about dumb [ __ ]
yeah the small stuff is so small people
like mad when they get the wrong milk
like seriously go to star but you know I
travel a lot you gonna Starbucks and
like I asked for almond milk I'm like
this [ __ ] bought a seven dollar coffee
like it's crazy the [ __ ] is a matter
with the people we need to start some
sort of cultural rule that anybody who's
mean to somebody that works at Starbucks
should get punched in the throat look it
should be a cup of need like it's the
collective responsibility of somebody to
punch that person in the face we don't
condone that here I like working here so
I just can't even laugh at some of this
stuff I don't work here I don't work
here punch people in the face I'm glad
you made the point about gratitude it
really is it really is sort of central
to some of the things that we're you
know we've got dr. Glenn Fox who's a
specialist in gratitude we'll put you a
by the way he'll put you in an fMRI
machine stimulate gratitude stimulate
different emotional states and watch
what happens in your brain he's an
expert on that it truly is a better
outcomes better life better health
better recovery momentum i believe in it
the most the people's perspective is
broken but watching you just call it
friends randomly now and tell me love
them it's really work nice like yeah I
don't know I'm like really I'm tilt on
this gratitude thing like people's
perspectives are completely broken and
parents sending their kids to a third
world country for four days to build a
house ain't gonna [ __ ] fix it
so you talk I'm gonna have some students
ask some questions a bit so I want you
to get lined up the ones who've already
prepared questions and then we'll open
up and line up kids I want to ask you
but I want I want to ask it yeah exactly
line them up
why dreams are important and these
people were picked they're in class and
they wanted to I should question it and
then could we do more just randoms
behind do that yeah and but I want to
talk about dreams and the importance of
dreams yeah you have one dream that you
have stated so often it's almost as if
it's you know not only going to be but
you tell everyone about a friend Adam
Shire who was the architect of Siri and
and Bixby at Samsung he's one of the
greatest AI people in the world and he
calls them verbally stated goals he says
once I commit to something I tell
everyone I know because that commits me
and it also opens the world to sort of
help me what's your verbally stated goal
I'm gonna buy the New York Jets
I'm coming drunk your youngest [ __ ]
you'll see it it's a hundred percent
gonna happen like I don't even know why
it's so obvious to me like
I genuinely think back to the world
helping I actually believe recently I
had a weird dream it was very vivid the
opportunity finally happened and I was
in a great spot it's like it was like 20
years from now I was right there but I
wasn't all the way financially there and
I and then I just like everybody knew
that the moment was upon us because the
Johnson family was selling the Jets and
then the country rallied and go funded
the rest of it it's funny I'll make this
very USC tout Vayner sports as a sports
agency that my brother and I started
it's three years old it's doing
extremely well we have 25 guys we
wrapped we love football we're all about
it is our passion we had the great
fortune of being in the final three to
get Sam Donald so I flew this is the
second year our company's like two
seconds old but because of who I am and
because of who Sam is we were in the mix
legitimately in the mix much to the like
shock of like the sports agency world so
we fly to Sam South I fly from family
vacation
I remember Sam's dad calls and goes it's
this time this is the only slot this is
one we're doing it and I remember like
me and AJ working on logistics and like
the only way we could do it was I had to
get like a private plane which I don't
like being bougie but like [ __ ] it this
is the moment like you know so we get
there and it's like the greatest and
they're the best I don't know how many
of you interact with Sam at this time
here but like the best dude and all this
good stuff and it gets to the final
moment of the pitch and we're just
wrapping up and I look at Sam and his
parents I go darn 'old listen to me and
listen to me good if I had my choice of
Sam going with Vayner sports and going
number one overall to the Browns and
mine you if Sam had decided to go with
Boehner Sports he didn't but if he did
it would have changed the trajectory of
our company they would have like been
disproportionately Burrage I would've
changed everything
I go if I had my choice of you going to
Vayner sports with us and going number
one overall to the Browns or you not
going with us but going three to the
Jets
I'm telling God right now I want you to
go to the Jets and we were in the green
room because we represented Josh Jackson
that
draft and he gets picked and I'm like
there's this incredible clip of Sam
getting drafted and hugging his parents
and me in the background looking like a
weird [ __ ] stalker and like he gets
drafted and like I hug his mom like one
second late like literally she just had
Sam then she turns to me and she hugs me
and she whispers and she's like you told
God to do it so yeah I really think I'm
gonna buy the Jets and I think America's
gonna love it I hope it happens while
Sam's still quarterback because that
won't happen you get a helper player
that won't happen
only because you know I'm a marathon
runner back to everything I just told
you I will not do short-term behavior I
need another 20 to 25 years but I will
do it I will retire Sam's number there
you go
that's a great thing to say students
come on up and ask questions of Gary Vee
thank you so much I'm over here come on
over here getting the light Sam hi hi hi
thank you so much for coming my question
is about the process of selling yes a
lot of entrepreneurs now attribute their
success to how they can sell their ideas
themselves and their products yes so I'm
curious how technology and social media
have changed your process of selling and
how you're still able to maintain a lot
of close relationships when you're
communicating with so many people at a
time well there's a couple things to
talk about this if you notice the way
you said that one of the things I'm
worried about and want to bring up to
the culture is selling their idea
themselves right
a lot of that is talking about getting
funding that's b2b selling what I think
is happening if you look at a lot of
people they're great at selling to a
singular venture capital because they
can make a great deck talk about their
pedigree but when their business runs
they're very bad at selling to the
actual consumer so for me my whole world
has only been about the consumer it has
nothing to do with b2b it has nothing to
do with anything I will never allow
anybody to have leverage over me and the
end consumer so my my selling hasn't
adjusted in a social media world
it's just excelled what I've always
naturally done
which is engagement at scale and reverse
engineering and asking questions and
listening to what you actually value
versus what my audacity wants you to
value selling to a VC and getting
funding is the furthest thing from
selling to the end consumer thank you
you're welcome
okay it's a pleasure and you're known to
be able to predict what's gonna happen
down the line with companies like
Facebook Instagram now you're high in
audio content my question would be what
is your prediction going down the next
10 15 years where our society is going
to be in regards to mental health and
what is social medias impact gonna be in
assisting that change so thank you so
look I've been to bounce here a little
bit first of all let's talk about social
media for one second
social media is pypes social media
impact is zero the humans that put out
content within it social media has
changed nobody social media has exposed
everybody so there is no social media
there's no Riki social media it spikes
so we're I think we're gonna be with
mental health is in a much better place
I'm so thankful that I get to watch this
happen nobody talked about exercise in
America 40 years ago right like like
Jack LaLanne like like like you know
what I mean like so I think if I think
the biggest comp to mental health is
physical health in America over the last
thirty years nobody talked about
exercising nobody talked about eating
healthy so I'm very excited I think
you're gonna see a lot of
consumerization around it I think you'll
see a lot of meditate I think there will
be a soul cycle of meditation I think
we're gonna eliminate a lot of stigma
which is gonna allow for healthy
conversation I'm very very optimistic
what's gonna happen over the next 20
years I really am
great love to hear it thank you
hi my name is Piper and I'm wondering
for many people graduating moving new
cities what sort of advice you have for
building your community and the right
people around you being self aware you
know like if you're an extrovert
it's a layup like just go outside and
say what's up but if you're introverted
put in real work to create safe places
to meet people spend a lot of time
networking with people that you feel
safe with finding people to introduce
you to in those markets
I really think all of this is one big
game of self-awareness and if you're
introverted your whole life at 22 moving
to a new city is not when you Rema
you'll ously become a social butterfly
so you need to lean into who you are and
what you can do is spend a lot of time
doing homework of people that you knew
from year older than you that are in
that town or a friend that has a cousin
in that town and feel comfortable in
your process but the ROI is always
people so meet as many people as
possible in that new place but do it
your way not my way or the way that it's
supposed to do do it your way
great thank you so much yo yo what do
you have a [ __ ] beat summon that's it
mates real pleasure how are you I'm good
how are you good thank you for coming
I'm gonna be here so my question is how
do you know when a business opportunity
or venture is worth their time and when
do you say no when so many people would
say yes in that situation I think too
many people over value their time when
their time is worth nothing so this is
my favorite one like I love when I love
when people like yo is this worth my
time I'm like well well and it's in a
business context I'm like well how much
money is your business making they're
like yo I don't have one yet I'm like
well your time is worth dick zero
so I think people are people are
audacious with their time their fancy
before their fancy so everything's worth
your time when you're at zero
you may bail I'm a big believer of going
I'm in yes culture my whole game is yes
, I'm not a great person to ask the no
thing I think there's people that are
more disciplined that no I just like the
value of yes and then if I'm a week an
hour a year in and I realize it's not
right I leave I bail because I'm not
worried about the loss because I'm not
hearing anybody's opinions I think every
I think you get context you know the
reason I like starting up and stopping
businesses is because I like the context
like right now I'm super hot on this
thesis that sports trading cards are
about to explode again so I'm spending
an ungodly amount of I mean like I spent
four and a half hours looking at
qualitative data and quant data on eBay
around giannis rookie cards from prism
created PSA ten four and a half hours I
don't have like three minutes for people
that are running like ten million dollar
businesses for me so I like saying yes
because I know I'm learning things and
then if I decide it's not worth it
I'll bounce so a couple things I would
tell you is one we need less audacity
right and we need more tasting and so
and the and I know when it's time to say
no after I've said yes and realize that
they're tasting it it's no you know many
people hate oysters but have never had
one that's how I think about that
question so when did you know Wine
Library was a great vehicle for
entrepreneurship and did you ever think
about quitting
I knew Wine Library was right because my
biggest goal at 18 years old
was to go and work for my family
business for a decade I stayed longer to
build a massive business for my parents
because I love them so much and I had to
give I had a a give more than I took and
so they gave me so much
including [ __ ] life itself and so you
know it was a brain twist of like how do
I do this so the
this thing I'm proud of on earth is that
from when I tell kids to be patient
there they don't know my narrative a lot
of times I as a 22 year old kid worked
for my parents business for 12 years
every day every Saturday gave up my
entire social life during my 20s which
is the prime took my family business
from a 3 to a 65 million dollar business
and then left at 34 years old with no
money because I never paid myself more
than $100,000 a year because I poured
all the money back into the business and
I own 0.0 percent of the business
because that's what immigrants do it's a
different model right like it's the
family when a family starts a business
it's the family business and you don't
get the business until the family dies
like and I wanted to do other things so
I came I did my thing I changed the
course of my parents financial life the
way they changed and created the course
of my life and then I was ready to do my
own thing at 34 with nothing so when
people are impatient at 26 I laugh
because I only started at 34 for me
because the first 12 years was for them
and so I knew that was right from the
get because that was my mission cool
thank you bro hello thank you so much
for coming I'm curious to know given
that you have your hands and so many
business opportunities and other
interests at any given time what do you
think is the key to your productivity
gratitude for sure and I have a general
thing that really works for me which is
I think 99% of things don't matter so
that allows me to not get bogged down by
anything and I'm a big fan of juggling
46 balls and being okay with nine of
them dropping versus only trying to hold
up one and making sure it doesn't drop
so a disproportionate comfort with
failure enormous gratitude and a
perspective on what it all means in the
scheme of things period
take some questions from the two
microphones for a couple minutes
yeah how much time do we have left
overall we got about 20 minutes good
then we got a couple things to say no we
got one
we're good we're good yeah yeah I was I
was low-balling yeah nice yeah go bro
hey what's up Gary my name's Tony I
appreciate Union content thanks for
coming thanks I'm uh
McAfee in the Marine Corps and a grad
student here at Marshall school business
the US military lies on a clear chain of
command to execute the mission would you
have any thoughts on Veterans culture
and business meaning I do have some
thoughts but I want to make sure I'm
understanding the question so I
understand click like do I think they
Matt well post exactly tremendously I
think the biggest issue and you know
this is depending on the nature of what
their course was in the military where
the services were providing for this
country like how extreme is some of the
stuff they went through to me the
discipline and the skill set speaks to
upper management in an incredible way
doesn't necessarily speak to
entrepreneurship can speak to
entrepreneurship but the biggest thing
is like people that went into combat
versus didn't have so many different
variables but yeah I mean people that
are great at teamwork and being part of
a machine make for incredible employees
Thanksgiving you're welcome to come over
here
or switch alternate okay thanks for
coming my name is bar hey my question is
so you're always in the media and you're
a big social image yes and I was
wondering on a day-to-day basis how do
you monitor your mentality and mindset
to make sure that your thoughts and
other people's opinions don't change the
goals you set for yourself and who you
are as a person I just talk to myself
all day long you know like dude other
people's thoughts was that went away a
long time ago there's nothing that
happens in business right like of other
people's opinions that's harder than
like having like like peer pressure in
high school in college and staying the
course once I was able to get over like
the girl that I liked wanted me to do
something that I didn't
do and I didn't do it then I was like
everything else was easy
thank you welcome hey bro I spent 10
years the Marine Corps too so there's a
program here in three years ago I
learned about you so I always tell guys
now coming out and women that you should
probably listen to for days straight
like Gary Vee I say it all the time
thank you
I used to be go to school go to school
go to school now I hear you saying you
know when you're 22 now is the time to
look now is the time to lose yes you
know long story short we've I heard you
speak once and this marine stepped up
and he said hey how do I get five
minutes in front of anybody and you said
you're a veteran just ask for five
minutes if they don't give you five
minutes and you know there are
anti-american and I didn't say that and
then I can say that and then Tommy Knapp
asked us to go reach out to some
entrepreneurs and I asked you for five
minutes so we didn't get that chance so
thank you for that but I want to invite
you we're having a graduation party the
the whole veteran community here at
Marshall we're having something on May
4th if you're around come be a part of
the team that's all I gotta say so thank
you so much for the invite you'll
appreciate that some away that day for
my mom's birthday but I appreciate that
and I appreciate your words bro and I
appreciate your service for real thank
you
hey Gary my name is Raj and a big fan of
you thank you so I work in a emergency
room um
see people like I mean done the daily
people get paralyzed yes but don't even
happen you know isn't their fault right
my dad grew up with polio my mom had a
brain aneurysm almost died when I was
like in the first grade so help for me
is number one and I see people me too by
the way I can complain all the time
preach everything dude I don't even give
a [ __ ] about entrepreneurship or
business yeah no no no yeah I'm a great
serious I love what I do but like I
could buy the Jets tomorrow and then get
a text at my kids and wife were hit by
bus and died and do you think I'd be
pumped and I owned the Jets what's a
matter of people yeah no no I agree
dude I think [ __ ] health is number
one well you should be your your set bro
you won Raj I'm being dead serious yeah
if you actually internalize the
perspective between your parents and
what you see day-to-day you should be
happy in perpetuity no I am dude it's
weird but I wake up neuro I I wake up
every [ __ ] morning and pray it and say
whatever is out there thank God I am
alive and my family's life that's the
most important thing to me on everything
I wake up every I'm being real
nothing on earth scares me because every
time I wake up and somebody didn't call
me in the middle of night right
like I'm super pumped to I wake up every
morning fired up because I'm like
another day that something atrocious
didn't happen to the nine people that I
love the most I mean it guys perspective
is the game like realizing what we're
talking about and then realizing the
reason you shouldn't value everybody's
opinions is because they don't actually
give a [ __ ] about your life they're
worried about their own like get off
your [ __ ] high horse nobody gives a
[ __ ] about what's going on with you yeah
no that's a good way to think about it
so the cool dudes so you've one life no
I mean I I bring this up because dude I
see so much like and I don't know it
might just be my like surroundings but I
see so much negativity and I just like
my goal in life honestly is to bring as
much positivity as I can to everyone
around me so just put out the contact do
that daily how can I like do that like
do what I do like crazy just post like
host [ __ ] positive perspective like
less [ __ ] swans and [ __ ] blow up
swans and [ __ ] pools and more [ __ ]
positive [ __ ] no no wait a mean how can
you nobody followed me either
I started bro everybody starts with zero
followers yeah what do you mean how can
you take your [ __ ] phone turn the
[ __ ] camera round hit record and say
some positive [ __ ] and post it let me do
it right now do it right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] micro
thank you so much dude you're awesome I
love you just posted I'll share that
[ __ ] you got everything I'm gonna share
it and change your [ __ ] life you so
much
[Applause]
hi Gary
hello so follow that [ __ ] so I have a
question for you by the way this dude
gave me a book that is like literally
the textbook of my brain I've literally
not stopped thinking about it and like
literally I've done this entire
interview kiss that dude did everything
and still have not been able to
comprehend that I've never seen my
thoughts in textbook form and you just
handed it to me in that room an hour ago
and I'm freaking the [ __ ] out because I
generally think we're gonna put it out I
think so too I think it's gonna bridge
the gap between your content and people
contextually I agree I'm very capable at
the macro but the reason I couldn't get
into a school like this is I'm not
interested in the micro you put it into
the micro thank you thank you
and everybody learns different right
like I learned my way but like for a lot
of people what you did is I can't wait
to like really analyze it go ahead
what's your question so you talk about
putting out content and the importance
of it for startups and companies and you
know so my question is there's different
ways to do that right there's the
documentation way where you like like I
don't put it on all the different
platforms yep which is a little bit more
long-term building brand yeah and then
there's creating content for like ads
video ads and everything right so I know
the end goal is to do all of it and do
it at scale and do it on every platform
as much as possible yes right so how
would you choose in the starting steps
pick one just pick one and it doesn't
matter like you know what's the best
about picking one you'll never know the
alternative anyway go pick one done
already done flip a [ __ ] coin done
like people's you know what I mean like
everybody here is thinking about like
these three options like right like pick
one because there's no chance you'll
ever know what would have happened
anyway I passed on uber twice in the
angel round right so right now based on
what's about to happen
I probably passed on 800 million dollars
right nice solid track to the Jets but
the reason I'm super pumped about it is
cool looks bad on my P&L but maybe if I
did that different things would have
happened in different speeches and
different opportunities and maybe I
would have been in London on a day that
I wasn't and I would have been hit by a
bus and I'd be dead as [ __ ] that's why
you just picked one done I love you I
love you more
hey Gary thanks for coming out yeah my
name is an ear and my question for you
is what is your best guess on how the
next economic collapse is gonna play out
my my hope it's my hope is it's based on
the college debt crisis my hope because
then we're gonna blame colleges which is
wrong because we need to be look
becoming accountable but I think he'll
bring a healthy conversation to the top
but I have zero clue
like macro global I cannot if I knew I
would sell all my [ __ ] the day before
and rebuy all that [ __ ] the next day
they him you got thank you so Gary thank
you I was exposed to you in 2017 out
walls on the marine corps and I was
really debating over Ian's listing read
your book I asked Gary we decide not to
I'm glad I didn't
my question is on networking we started
a club here called the canna Club and
the Trojan cannabis networks are
obviously centered around cannabis this
room is full of leaders including my
partners Joseph Internet that's up there
do you have any as far as leadership do
you have any type of like tips tips you
know like for networking like Detroit
I'm sorry I'm sorry man I listen to you
every single I'm so flattered you don't
to be sorry
look my biggest thing about leadership
is people confused about leadership when
you're a leader you work for everybody
else they don't work for you yeah I'm
the CEO of a company that has a thousand
employees which means I have a thousand
bosses and I actually genuinely believe
that it's not like a cliche headline I
don't know like you're in the listening
business your job is to put everybody in
a position to succeed so what would be
your great like an event like as if you
were a student what would you want as a
student I don't know but an event like
for a networking event like alcohol
I mean there's no one-size-fits-all
right this goes back to why listening
works some students want it to be a
gateway drug to a job others want it to
be a gateway drug to funding another
person wants it to be a gateway drug to
another hookup I don't [ __ ] know like
there's a lot of different things people
want out of a networking event I think
the job of creating a networking event
is to bring value to seven different
psychographic cohorts instead of one
okay appreciate that thank you Gary got
it hi hey Jess yes I get a cold email
from the case Wis president and it says
we'd like to do a Gary Vee sneaker so I
thought that when I read it I was like I
wonder if they think because I started
really exploding on Instagram I was like
is this like an influencer deal like am
I gonna like I don't do that [ __ ] but I
but the way it was written I'm like are
these [ __ ] talking about my
signature on an actual sneaker so I met
Barney in a in a cafe in LA and he was
like look we think entrepreneurship is
the next pillar we can't compete with
Nike with athletes we can't compete with
adidas with culture and easy right now
we think that you're you could be the
face of a sneaker that does well for me
it worked because I want to refurbish
iconic brands in my career so k-swiss
was an iconic brand when I was a kid and
so it was super interesting we were able
to put the deal together and it's been a
monster hit for k-swiss and for me like
when Europe when you're an 80s 90 bit
Jersey baby and and like you grow up
when the signature sneaker thing
happened I mean like this is it's so
insane to me that people wear sneakers
with my signature on it
it's super fun more than anything else
and I've learned a lot about
refurbishing iconic brands which will
service me well it was much more for me
to have another taste at I I remember
when I did it there was two very big
different camps one that thought it was
super cool and one thought that I was
gonna be a colossal failure and be bad
for me but back to some of the themes
I've said to you tonight it was a win
for me from day one
because I was gonna learn for something
that I want to do later and if it was a
colossal failure it was just gonna be a
fun joke for me and my friends that one
time when I thought was an idiot and
thought I could sell sneakers thank you
welcome hey how's it going Gary for one
New York or to another
thank you stop by you gotta so my
question is about happiness yeah so
Henry David Thoreau's got a quote okay
most men live in quiet desperation and
they do so till the day they die okay is
it basically just as simple as just
trusting your gut yes okay that's all I
wanted to know because I think trusting
your gut sounds more like dying on your
own sword yeah I just want to lose my
way okay
do you understand no no I get it like I
want to lose my way if I'm gonna lose I
want to lose my way not the way somebody
told me to do it because then you lost
twice how many times you guys have lost
twice it [ __ ] sucks
yes thank you you're welcome [ __ ] hey
man I think we live in this really
interesting time where everybody wants
to better themselves without looking at
themselves no [ __ ] yeah but I also think
it kind of like shows up in
entrepreneurship where you see all these
people with all these quick tips and
these nuggets right you know take a cold
shower every morning or do this stretch
- it's all [ __ ] in my opinion some
carriers within the social media age how
do you remain authentic while also
pitching new ideas and trying to make
people's lives better by speaking your
truth it's really easy to be authentic
don't say [ __ ] you don't believe in yeah
thank you welcome
and and you know why this is important
and you'll appreciate this in a world
where people are pandering to vanity
metrics you know many people hit me up
to like Gary I want to be this and and
I'm trying to do this on my social media
and I'm like then don't put up
half-naked pictures on your Instagram
and they're like yeah but that gets more
likes and I'm like you're [ __ ] idiot
like you just told me you're unhappy and
you want this to happen but you're
pandering to likes on a platform that's
not going to be as relevant in a decade
like remember when people used to get
remember when you were in junior high
and you got work for you like third
grade
that's [ __ ] you guys are so young for
the older people here remember when
somebody took you out of your top eight
on MySpace like that used to really
[ __ ] hurt it doesn't hurt as much now
you got it
hey Gary I'm Jackie I actually quit my
job my corporate jobs figure and I
wanted to do what I wanted to do and
pursue and I everyone around me kept
telling me I made a mistake right so I
was living my truth really excited doing
what I was doing but then I kept
listening to everything everyone around
me and I started feeling regret yes for
pursuing what I really loved and I
started listening to those voices and
fell into depression yes to the point
where I ended up losing everything yes
it's awful I stumbled upon your content
and it started to motivate me to get
back on my feet I'm at Ground Zero right
now what advice do you have for me don't
listen to them again that's the only you
were on your way you let insecurity and
valuing others opinion [ __ ] you up what
if it's a constantly in your face and
you're doing sniping you can stop
talking to your parents as much being
serious this is one big game of what
you're listening to and if your parents
or your loved one or your spouse or your
best friends unhappy they're going to
subconsciously or consciously make you
on a bee misery loves company
the end one last thing I saw you in
Dallas four weeks ago at we live I don't
even remember the whole sailing event
yep
I miss my opportunity to take a picture
with you and I said I was never gonna
miss that again you just let people that
are losing get you into a wrong place
and even if those are people that you
love the most
you need to mitigate how much you're
listening to them if they're constantly
your face get out of the [ __ ] face
and my job because I hate it what I was
doing and I actually love what I'm doing
but I'd listen to others losing players
lose yeah thank you so much
hey Gary my name's Alex first of all I
really want you to buy the [ __ ] Jets
I would be like the coolest thing this
is nerve-racking um a few weeks ago you
can you post like this really beautiful
tribute to Nipsey Hussle like a
beautiful video and and i've and i
followed you for maybe a year or so and
I didn't I wasn't aware of the
relationship you two had and I was
wondering if you could speak to just
that and how in if C was is both an
entrepreneur and as a man Nipsey would
be giving his version of the exact stuff
that I'm saying right now he was a pure
energy that genuinely wanted other
people to win he was immensely talented
he was hard-working he was patient he
cared about legacy he cared about others
and it's a devastating loss for me
personally it really is I really liked
him a lot in a way that I didn't feel
about others and I think for a lot of
people here who didn't really know
Nipsey as well when this went down I'm
sure you probably were caught off-guard
by how it hits so many people that you
did know about and that only that
reaction only happens when somebody's
truly authentic and like as a genuinely
good force and he had his shortcomings
and we all do he was a special dude um
um it's really like tough man like I'm
really really genuinely sad that the
world misses out and then I get
optimistic and think he now because of
this tragedy becomes bigger than he ever
could have been without it and all that
kind of stuff and if you listen very
carefully to him he had it figured out
and you mentioned earlier about how you
prefer marathons / Sprint's I know I was
like a huge thing for like for his
methodology was that the marathon
continues and whatnot so he was a
special dude it's a big loss thank you
hi my name is animal and first of all
thank you for coming we haven't had a
quick question I came all the way from
India to the US so that I could get a
special specialized degree and a
master's program in data science and the
thing was that you come here you get
into a good company get the experience
and then you start something of your own
in my mind and my family is mine that's
the correct way to go but when I look
online in social media everybody seems
to be demonizing going to college and
getting a specialized technical degree
because if you do that or you don't have
the entrepreneurial spirit because you
would have just quit and started
[ __ ] them so what's your thought on that
and you know this is the right know what
- don't don't listen to me or them
listen to yourself just cos
entrepreneurship popular now you would
have been super [ __ ] right when I was
your age if you're super wrong now
you'll be super right in 20 years the
[ __ ] goes in circles
most of the entrepreneurs that I see
even back in my country who I know
personally they're mostly people who are
flexing on Instagram creating a brand
around it and then using it to get more
followers who pay more it's something of
a circle that they've created but I feel
that I am more technical and I have an
actual physical proud via value to give
learn to just create Instagram pose
you'll be like yo yo yo
let me tell you how it's gonna happen
it's the same way that so many of my
friends flexed on me when I was your age
they flexed on me because they got a
degree and got a six-figure job and got
a BMW they're gonna flex in the short
term you're gonna flex in perpetuity but
that's on you dick that has nothing to
do with me your parents America India
and the fake [ __ ] flexors on
Instagram you winning is you all right
thank you
hi Carrie how are you my name is Shiva
I'm a great fan of you thank you for a
while thank you here's I want to thank
my friend who gave me this opportunity
to come and meet you that's very nice
I'm having in entrepreneurship for the
last 15 years and I failed in two
startups and now I'm on my third startup
and I've launched two weeks back so I've
been in the entrepreneurial journey
where I have seen a lot of failures I
made my million bucks but I failed
and then again I'd never gave up but the
thing my question to you I've got two
questions for you the first thing is
like about a family and I've been always
hustling like I believe in what I do and
even now what I'm doing I completely
believe in what I doing love so am i
doing justice to my family because you
know they are also going through this
struggle which I'm going through staying
away from the family working for this
let me ask you a question are you
capable of getting a job yeah well then
the question becomes very simple if
you're capable of getting a job you need
to speak to your family and ask them
like like to me they are supporting me
well then what then but it's just like -
it's my feeling like am i doing justice
or like are I'm being selfish like of
course you're being selfish yeah you
should be selfish everybody should be
selfish and you should be selfless you
should carry both those contradictions
empowering everything I should give to
my family
I'm giving 100% but still you know I'm
I'm staying away from the family and
focus more on my business my friend my
friend there's plenty of people that are
spending tons of time with their family
and bringing their family no value I'm
serious I love when people hit me up
they're like Gary Vee whatever like I
come home at 6 p.m. like you're always
traveling like I'm doing what's right
I'm like and I reply I'm like your
family might not like that you're home
yeah yes I have a lot of high school
friends that judge me right real quick
like showing your children how to live
is the most important thing you can do
yeah yeah I completely believe in that
well good yeah being home at six and
making pretend that you're happy with
that is not going to work basically I'm
from in years I'm traveling and staying
away from home for long like blah
months it's kind of like enough bro that
goes down to you and your family not me
not anybody here if you and your family
are cool with that
yeah and you want and if not then you
lost I understand that's you
communicating to them I understand I
have no context on that but what I can
tell you much like I told the last
gentleman this is all one big game of
one one your circumstances your life not
what worked for me I tell you what
worked for me and hope that it could be
a framework for you to have a proper
conversation with yourself just like
other people can share what works for
them this is one big game of
self-awareness if that works for you and
your partner then you won yeah she does
well then you [ __ ] won
thank you Gary yeah well you happy
honest my stud started so I hope I'm
definitely successful Thank You luck
brother thank you
[Applause]
is that an Atari hoodie fresh good for
sure $6.00 bid will feel enough
I [ __ ] love good will for sure for
sure name's Toby really interested in
the comp the combining of culture and
entrepreneurship especially with the
surge of financial literacy and I'm in
hip hop as recently you know it's only
one savage relating great Nipsey Hussle
you know and the whole thing he did with
the marathon's store and angel sandy so
really just interesting trying to get
into that okay me and my friends would
be a really cool [ __ ] you know in terms
of like art installations right and like
different cool things with tech right
and basically trying to you know break
out into that field and trying to find
that you know that person that you latch
onto yes or you know you know build that
next thing with right so my question is
right like we have some really cool [ __ ]
for gonna right now right with gonna
yeah I got a man I know you're like
really into of him and his camp right so
like how do i how do we get our [ __ ] to
him you know we're gonna FaceTime
let's do it let's do it let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
look what you know unfortunately he's
he's the best at it - I thought he just
picked up I think the thing there is
like it's just taking at-bats like first
of all this wasn't that bad yeah and it
and we missed right it's not available
for sure but you can DM hit look guys
there's a lot of interesting things that
happen in DMS one of them is business
development like your ability to take
what you just showed me and DM gonna and
little baby and [ __ ] like anybody they
auntie grizzly and whoever the [ __ ] you
want to get to for sure all you need is
one to say yes for sure like it's just
that bat yeah we just cooking at bat
yeah right for sure the last three times
I face time I picked up right for fans
this time he didn't so that's just the
way it is but you don't need me to
co-sign that you could just hit up
people for sure for sure it's it's
literally just one at-bat you know sure
appreciate you man you got it yeah
let's go let's do like speed round cuz I
feel bad for everybody standing up hey
how are you and only for USC students
please good bro good I'm max Mike watch
reviews I work with my brother in app
development and social media marketing a
little bit yep what's your suggestion
for working with family but not
fracturing the relationship love your
brother more than money and I definitely
do then you'll be just fine
thank you so much you got it Gary my
name is Devin so right now I am working
with my dad I'm helping him with
marketing for his manufacturing company
I know that with your father in Wine
Library you kind of face some resistance
as you brought it into the more
e-commerce side and my crack yeah just
just confusion right my dad was like
don't sit on the computer you got to be
on the floor selling wine okay
there's a misunderstanding more the
technology on his end there's you know
there's always sort of facing that same
gap I feel in terms of marketing you
know what listen and I want to address
it cuz I like that last few like I
understand that exchange like I'm not
I'm not mad at him I hope he I hope that
nothing will make me happier than
posting this clip in four years and
showing that his company did a trillion
I got oh there's a world of abundance I
want him to win it's the same thing
you're going through my big point to him
during that exchange is the same one I'm
about to make to you which is when
there's a father and mother that runs
the business in a family business when
you're asking for money from somebody
you have to recognize that you're in the
position of asking and so what I did
with my dad was I knew he had the power
and then the reason I told him to go and
execute and stick it to me is because
that's what I want for him because
that's what I did to my dad what my dad
did well was he gave me just enough room
but what kids always don't do well with
parents is when they get the opportunity
they have to understand they have to
execute to give their parents more
confidence but they go and shoot for the
Grand Slam I just hit singles I just did
10% more than we did a year ago on
Saturday which gave my dad kids right
now are just shooting for the moon and
striking out you're you're good it's
something you you once said I just
remember you said like advice for
somebody who wants to get close to the
CEO get promoted fast yes is it actually
that was the answer just get close to
yeah okay close getting off right and
you said get done what you want done and
only that basically get done what that
person had done like the tasks that you
you know you order and don't
above and beyond and try to do things
that are I don't remember the context
but keep playing with me here don't
worry about time I know like um let's
hack a little bit go ahead I'm just like
what are you asking me I'm curious how
you sort of dealt with the the contrast
between your knowledge of technology in
that day and age and your father's and
the resistance there with respect okay I
respected my dad came here and worked as
at like kids don't respect what the hell
did to get there they have complete lack
of context they take it for granted and
they don't understand what the dirt was
like to even get to this point at the
same token I died on my sword I
communicated to my dad with respect now
I got lucky because my dad gave me more
room than I see other people giving kit
people but the reason he did that was
because I worked in a liquor store every
day when I was 14 and 15 and 16 and 17
and had shown him things that gave him a
little more confidence a bunch of kids
never work in their family business go
to college take a gap year and then come
back and think the running [ __ ] when
they've never been in the business
you've got employees that have been in a
business that deserve respect but you
don't just come and be the heir apparent
so I rolled in with respect but you need
to continue to articulate it just just
to just to say I'm going in with with
the full mindset of trying to learned it
from my dad you know how he is a CEO
you're right you're at them now yearning
for money you're at the mercy of how
much room he'll be able to prove that
give you to prove [ __ ] I've been doing a
good job so far better than the last guy
I believe that by the way I'm feeling
good about this but I don't feel bad I
just I'm using you to make a macro point
but coming back to you I think it's a
game of patience potentially like like
right like yeah you know that's a
because that make sense you know we're
gonna have a liquor store 15 - yeah dude
I would say it's patience right like
it's it's just patience right like it
seems like the biggest thing that your
dad would be wrong is not give you the
at-bats the room the biggest mistake
that you would make is trying to hit a
grand slam on every at-bat okay
excellent good questions good quite
weird to lose the theater
yeah I want to ask
Oh give me a minute Oh ask how many how
many students are here how many students
are here how many student excellent how
many students from like my class blends
class okay all right I want students
from my class in Glens class any student
who has a quick takeaway or a quote or
an insight that you learned today to
line up at the mics this is just as a
Gary Vee request David so I want my
students any student it has a quote or
something they've learned today to come
to the mics in a second I want to come
here we don't have time for more
questions so guys guys there's there's
there's a thousand people here not
everyone gets a selfie all right all
right seriously he can't say no I can
let's be let's let's let's respect our
guests so any of our get any of our
students ready a few minutes okay
all right you it's unbelievable what
let's thank Gary Vee
I'm so good so good up for that
five my gosh thank you so much thank you
the grippe Center for entrepreneurial
studies is the oldest entrepreneur
program in the country started in 1971
yes you can teach entrepreneurship and
not everybody is is ready to sort of
take the leap at 22 we've we've got a
great tradition some of our our alums
have made us look very good from the
founder of Salesforce to MySpace to
Kinko's to some company called tinder I
don't know about it exactly but I hear
it's doing well but just a great
tradition of entrepreneurs graduating
from here and we we decided instead of
giving you an award that we've already
given is to create an award and this is
the first devil ever hustle award for
the entrepreneur and this is the
entrepreneur to Gary Vaynerchuk thank
you thank you
one more time for Gary Vee thank you
guys thank you so much
it's been a great day to be a Trojan
it's been a great time having Gary be
back here he's our new our new you
hopefully be our adjunct professor of
entrepreneurship one day but have a
great week it's great day to be a Trojan
fight on find out thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you